for vr i
kind of had experiences with two labs i
wanted to do this kind of hard super
realistic experience which was the
military
experience where they really try to
simulate what it's like to be in combat
so um in the travel lab i saw we just
wore goggles but if you went into their
real
lab they would they would pump in smells
they would vibrate the floor to emulate
kind of driving motor shaking explosions
and stuff like that and then i went to
this lab at stanford called the virtual
human interaction lab which is like the
magic realism
side of the vr world and they are really
inspired by gerund linear and kind of
this idea of alternate bodies so one of
the things that i did in there was they
never told me what i was going to do
they just said come to the lab and i got
there one day and they said get down on
all fours and wear these like infrared
markers they put them on my back and
they put them on my arms okay fine and
they snapped on the vr and i was a cow
right
and i was like okay
what they're what they're experimenting
with is jaron lanier kind of famously
asked this question of why do you have
to have a human body in virtual reality
right and he said imagine that you're a
lobster okay you drive arm one with this
arm you drive arm two with this arm how
do you drive the rest of the arms right
so the question is how how well can you
adapt to these novel bodies so they put
me in a cow and i could see my cow
doppelganger across from me because it's
actually very hard to wear a helmet and
crawl around on the floor and look at
your own body as a cow body so they did
we did all of these things that kind of
bonded me the cow like do this and the
cow would do that right and then they
said okay here's your job you have to
gain all of this weight so you reach a
certain number of pounds okay so i go
over and i eat i go over and i drink
and then they say go back to your
starting point because now we're going
to send you to the slaughterhouse
and then the floor
starts to shake and this truck
like it starts making that beep beep
beep back of noises and i freaked out
right i can hear myself i have a tape of
myself and and in it i'm yelling this is
brutal right like no one in particular
and vr is like being on stage you're not
supposed to break the illusion you know
of the fourth wall i am really scared
and it's because basically i have come
to empha emphasize with this other that
quickly right like i feel so responsible
for this other imaginary being and that
turns out to be what they were trying to
test in the real experiment what they
would have done afterwards is kind of
put me through all of these uh batteries
of tests to gauge how i felt about
animals and how likely i was to donate
to animal rights causes
and that was like that was a real
experience it was very visceral and the
other things that they did after that is
they made me a coral because they wanted
to see what how people would behave in a
body that's even on more unlike yourself
so like a like a c
and then they did a thing where they
gave me a third arm and the idea was how
quickly would i learn how to drive a
third arm and i'll tell you it happened
like that
it was okay so
in vr the third arm is coming out of my
chest and i'm wearing controllers on my
wrist they didn't tell me how to drive
it they just said make your third arm
move they said tap that thing
it was just like that it was an amazing
experience
yeah did i answer all these guys
um
both of these labs were trying to do
things for basically for pro-social
reasons to help people right to either
prevent a disorder cure disorder or kind
of make people more empathetic with
their environment with other people i
thought that was a pro a really like
awesome application of vr they were
talking about using it for with students
could you bring students in and instead
of
reading about global warming and the
effect on ocean life
would you be able to empathize with with
ocean life i thought that was a cool
idea um the big question for me is how
long does that effect last
right so i would love to see more
research that shows
how long what happens in vr lingers in
your real life
[Music]
you